la tempête balaie l'ouest de la france
des arbres arrachés les voitures
envolées et trois morts dont un
conducteur de camion écrasé par la chute
d'un arbre
la polémique après les incidents de la
nuit de la saint sylvestre à strasbourg
le procureur de la république avait mise
en cause l'attitude de la police il est
rappelé à l'ordre par jean pierre
chevènement est convoqué à la
chancellerie
la grande braderie des soldats
commençaient en région parisienne à
l'occasion de faire des affaires à
condition toutefois d'être vigilants les
prix affichés sont parfois trompeurs
la rentrée politique avec les échanges
de voeux traditionnels à l'elysée
l'occasion pour nous de jeter un coup
d'oeil sur cette année 97 pour le moins
riche en événements et puis enfin une
découverte dans la lutte contre le sida
certaines conditions l'organisme
disposerait de ses propres défenses pour
bloquer le virus les explications tout à
l'heure dans ce journal
madame monsieur bonsoir la tempête
frappe l'ouest de la france dans le
morbihan le finistère la loire
atlantique on ne compte plus les arbres
arrachés et les toits emportés à sucé
sur erdre près de nantes le conducteur
d'un camion a été tué par la chute d'un
arbre à redon en ille et vilaine c'est
une mini tornade qui a soufflé clocher
toiture au total cinq cent mille
personnes ont été privées d'électricité
en l'espace de quelques heures le vent a
soufflé jusqu'à 150 km/heure leur
partage d'olivier sioux et de gabriel
kamya aussi facilement qu'un château de
cartes les bateaux se sont couchés les
uns sur les autres
il a suffi de quelques minutes ce matin
pour que ce garage où il verne plusieurs
dizaines de voiliers fois dévastée par
la tempête s'est abattue sur toute la
façade sud de la bretagne
quelques minutes seulement pour réduire
à néant un rêve de plaisanciers 800 pour
vos parents préfèrent un allemand
tout va pour maubeuge à châteaugiron
près de rennes le toit de l'église et le
clocher n'ont pas résisté au rafale le
cimetière et la caisse d'epargne ont été
endommagés par les chutes de pierres au
nord de nantes vers 8 heures du matin la
chute d'un arbre a été fatale au
chauffeur de ce poids lourds dont la
cabine a été grattée il est mort sur le
coup la circulation sur plusieurs grands
axes a été perturbée par des semi
remorques renversé dans le seul
département du morbihan le plus touché
par les intempéries
les pompiers sont intervenus plus de 500
fois en douze heures
la tempête était prévue mais elle a
surpris par son intensité à lorient les
rafales de vent ont culminé à plus de
190 kilomètres heure ont été réveillés
par les bruits d'armes qui se cassait et
puis on avait plus lumière à la maison
alors a fallu attendre un petit peu plus
jour se lève pour voir ce qui s'était
passé
et puis va comme vous voyez tout est
arraché tout est cassé détruit en face
et l'horreur quoi paradoxalement c'est
sur les côtes que la tempête a été le
moins spectaculaire du coup certains
promeneurs s'aventure au plus près des
vagues sans toujours se rendre compte
des risques encourus ont pas quel
problème
votre avis s'adresse à tous pas combien
en ce moment des pointes à 150
avant on va vraiment pas perdre et blur
beaucoup des vacanciers ont prolongé le
réveillon du nouvel an jusqu'au week-end
des touristes imprudents
c'est justement ce qui s'il redoute le
plus il y aura dimanche
je pense surtout dimanche une très forte
mer et il est tout à fait nécessaire de
ne pas être imprudent sur les coaches la
tempête prévue dimanche devrait être
aussi forte et plus longue que celle
d'aujourd'hui en vendée et en
charente-maritime dans les deux-sèvres
les dégâts sont également importants on
ne compte plus les interventions des
pompiers et dans le calvados un orage de
grêle a provoqué un accident qui a coûté
la vie à deux personnes parce qu'à douce
est bon
il n'y a guère que les baraques de plage
à rester stoïque l'atlantique offrent
depuis hier son spectacle de nouvel an
création gratuite mais dangereuse mais
les sauveteurs n'ont pas eu à sortir
pêcheurs et plaisanciers ont bien suivi
l'avis de tempête de météo france
maintenue jusqu'à demain en fait c'est
surtout l'intérieur des terres qui a
subi l'affront du vent le mécanisme est
connue les arbres déracinés tombe sur
les lignes électriques
et voilà près de cinquante mille foyers
privés d'électricité
du côté de poitiers de châteauroux ou
encore sur l'île de ré quant aux
toitures elles n'ont pas toutes résister
c'est l'essentiel des interventions des
pompiers protéger ce qui peut encore
l'être
dans certains cas il n'est même plus
question de toi le hangar était penché
roussin qui est en fait quand on appuie
sortir il était à moitié pencher puis à
moitié écoulée tu es le car qui
maintenait le patois tueur et les
pompiers sont venus ce soir le vent
touchera encore les côtes mais aussi
l'est du pays il pourrait atteindre les
140 km la tempête a également sévi dans
l'ouest de l'angleterre provoquant là
aussi un accident grave dans lequel
trois personnes ont laissé la vie pour
demain les spécialistes de la météo
son pénis sont pessimistes avis de coup
de vent sur l'angleterre également mais
aussi sur tout l'ensemble de l'ouest et
puis sur la lorraine et les vosges
souffre en premier sur tout à l'heure
avec isabelle martinez la polémique
après les incidents de strasbourg et les
propos très critiques du procureur de la
république sur le comportement et
l'inefficacité selon lui de la police
les réactions sont très vives aussi bien
des syndicats de police que des
autorités locales
et l'on apprend ce soir que le procureur
de strasbourg est convoqué à la
chancellerie dès lundi au même moment la
première sanction est tombée concernant
une jeune fille qui avait tenté de
mettre le feu à une voiture elle a été
condamnée à 18 mois de prison ferme
arnaud boutet et jean-pierre blaster au
nom de la concertation entre la justice
et les services de l'état
edmond stenger devra s'expliquer devant
le garde des sceaux
hier soir le procureur de strasbourg
commentait ainsi le travail de la police
pendant les violences du nouvel an en ce
qui concerne
l'efficacité de la police judiciaire
elle est proche du zéro
je pense que si le procureur général
s'était déplacé en mesure de l'île des
vies
n'hésitez y est le procureur n'a donc
pas vu cela en quelques heures une
cinquantaine de voitures brûlées des
cabines téléphoniques et des abribus
saccagés les 400 policiers mobilisés
protéger avant tout les pompiers cible
des agresseurs face à eux des jeunes
âgés de 12 à 18 ans quand les policiers
arrivent et les pompiers la voiture elle
brûle déjà pas mal donc on trait choisir
un véhicule qui brûlait les sept
personnes interpellées mercredi soir
comparaissait aujourd'hui deux mineurs
sont placés sous contrôle judiciaire
quatre majeurs sont condamnés à des
peines de prison ferme de six a dit
moore parmi eux
cynthia condamnés pour l'incendié d'une
voiture devant chez elle 8 - ferme un
casier judiciaire vierge ses amis ne
comprennent pas travailler naturel était
tranquille et on retrouve c'est moche
comme elle ça fait réfléchir les autres
un petit peu ça or bon je pense être des
pensionnats qui réfléchissent pas mais
toi ça te fait réfléchir
hier soir huit véhicules ont encore
brûlés et c'est ainsi au tour de
strasbourg depuis quinze jours
garou en cinq mineurs dont un adolescent
de 11 ans a été interpellé par la police
dans la nuit de la saint-sylvestre neuf
voitures avaient été incendiées dans
cette banlieue de rouen une énigme près
de valenciennes trois personnes dont un
enfant de 9 ans a été retrouvé tué par
balles dans leur maison abscons
la maison était en feu ce sont les
pompiers qui les ont découverts et pour
le parquet la piste criminelle n'est pas
écartée
marianne masse le feu a principalement
touché la toiture et le premier étage de
la maison où ont été retrouvés les trois
victimes
c'est ce matin vers 8 heures que les
pompiers sont intervenus et n'ont
découvert les corps carbonisés qu'une
fois l'incendié éteint
stupeur dans le quartier on a vu la
toiture qui vole en éclats
c'est tout ce que j'ai vu ce matin fêter
quelque chose d'épouvantable des gens à
côté de chez nous qu'on sort pied puis
les voir après sortir mort c'est quelque
chose de ce gosse de 9 ans qui est l'âge
de notre petite fille c'est c'est
épouvantable on est vraiment vraiment ce
matin tout le monde est bouleversé
des chambres du premier étage les
pompiers dégageons les corps de maryse
et frédéric chignac 47 et 34 ans et de
jean michel neuf ans tous étaient
allongés sur leur ligne est atteinte de
plaies par balles une carabine a
également été retrouvé sur place
dans le voisinage personne n'a rien vu
rien entendu tout ce que l'on sait c'est
qu'il venait de passer trois jours à
eurodisney et semblait détendu le couple
vivent et abscons depuis quatre ans et
qui était même mariés l'an dernier je
les ai vus une première fois en mairie
et une seconde fois le jour de leur
mariage
mais ce sont des gens qui ne portait
vraiment pas à paroles d'après les
voisins que je connais très bien je n'ai
jamais entendu dire de mal de ces
personnes homicide ou suicide collectif
aucune des deux hypothèses n'est
privilégiée mais les enquêteurs devront
éclaircir les circonstances de ces trois
morts mystérieuses aucune effraction n'a
été constatée et l' incendie semble
avoir été provoqué intentionnellement
une autopsie des corps sera pratiquée en
début de semaine prochaine et à metz le
parquet a ouvert une information pour
assassinat après la mort de trois
personnes tués d'une rafale d'armé
automatique tirait à travers la porte
d'une boîte de nuit de la ville
les débuts des soldes coup d'envoi
aujourd'hui en région parisienne c'est
l'occasion aux principes de s'offrir un
meilleur prix les choses qui étaient
jusque là hors de portée à condition
bien sûr qu'il s'agisse de vrais soldes
il faut donc être vigilant
gilles marine est effrayée de la rue la
serviette en mal pas décidé
ces deux là n'ont pas l'intention
d'acheter quoi que ce soit dans le
centre commercial
ils sont là pour travailler ce sont les
agents de la répression des fraudes
nous avons concédé un relevé de près de
références en magasin par sondage et
puis nous reviendrons apavou loin des
dernières dispositions un contrôle de
routine le magasin a été choisi au
hasard son responsable devra fournir
tous les renseignements exigés par les
enquêteurs selon le nombre de manteaux
que vous avez vendu dans la
précédés voilà le nom et l'historique du
produit tel que ça a été décidée à tel
moment
l'une des fraudes les plus rentables
consiste en effet à proposer aux
consommateurs des produits bas de gamme
spécialement fabriquée pour l'occasion
et présentés comme des soldes mirifiques
d'avoir été achetée le plus loin de 30
jours avant la période deux seuls en
simples tongs et le vérifier nous allons
vérifier effectivement partir des
codes-barres auprès du siège de
l'entreprise
s'il est rare que de grandes enseignes
comme ce magasin se livrent à la fraude
d'autres ne s'en prive pas l'été dernier
l'union fédérale des consommateurs a
mené l enquête un produit soldé sur deux
relevait d'une infraction un chiffre
exagéré selon les agents des fraudes qui
admet toutefois que les clients a tout
intérêt à être prudent mais le fait
qu'il est l'ancien prix au niveau prix
c'est intéressant
c'est indispensable je n'achète que
quand il ya les deux pris l'affiché
et quand j'ai vu les articles avant
magasin et que bon bah ils sont solides
et afrique ou quoi cette année les
contrôles seront encore plus fréquents
notamment dans le meuble la bijouterie
les tapis trois secteurs qui détiennent
le record des infractions et après cette
bonne nouvelle des soldes car c'est
quand même une bonne nouvelle
un inventaire moins agréable celui des
augmentations de ce début d'année damien
thévenot l'impôt sur le revenu ne
baissera pas cette année comme l'avait
envisagé lance un gouvernement juppé en
revanche la csg va augmenter et passer à
sept et demi pour cent une hausse de
quatre points qui devrait être compensée
par la baisse des cotisations maladie
côté allocations familiales le
gouvernement jospin a décidé leur mise
sous condition de ressources
dorénavant toute famille avec deux
enfants ne doit plus percevoir plus de
25000 francs nets par mois pour
continuer à bénéficier des prestations
la location de garde d'enfants à
domicile
la ged est désormais réduite de moitié
quant aux intérêts d'emprunt liés à
l'achat d'un appartement il n'est plus
possible de les déduire de ses impôts
si vous êtes fumeur et automobilistes
la facture 4% d'augmentation sur les
cigarettes dès lundi et plus 10 centimes
sur le carburant à partir du 1 janvier
enfin les timbres fiscaux vont augmenter
160 francs au lieu de 150 pour une carte
d'identité et 4 cents au lieu de 350
pour un passeport quelques bonnes
nouvelles tout de même le rmi les
allocations familiales et le minimum
vieillesse sont revalorisés de 1,1 pour
cent quant à l'allocation spécifique de
solidarité pour les chômeurs en fin de
droits elle augmente de 3%
c'est une très mauvaise année pour la
vente des voitures en france malgré un
bon score en décembre avec une hausse de
7 9% des immatriculations
la vente des voitures a chuté sur
l'ensemble de l'année de près de 20%
un beau succès quand même celui de la
mégane qui reste la voiture la plus
vendue en france devant la clio et la
peugeot 306 alors que le mouvement des
chômeurs se poursuit dans treize
antennes des assedic jean claude gayssot
le ministre des transports a reçu tout à
l'heure une délégation de chômeurs qui
réclament la gratuité des transports en
ile-de-france pour cette première
rencontre avec des représentants du
gouvernement monsieur gayssot était en
principe accompagné de martine aubry
sébastien guibert vous êtes sur place la
réunion est terminée oui benoît et le
ministre des transports jean claude
gayssot a donc proposé aux représentants
des associations de défense des chômeurs
la création d'un chèque mobilité pour
les demandeurs d'emploi de la région
ile-de-france uniquement sous concert' n
conditions pour les chômeurs également
visés les jeunes de moins de 26 ans sans
ressources ou les allocataires du rmi je
vous propose tout de suite d'écoutés
la réaction du ministre jean claude
gayssot ainsi que celle d'un des
représentants des associations de
chômeurs bien fait je vous attaquer à
cette question avec y compris la volonté
de faire en sorte que et bien ces
centaines de milliers de personnes de
familles ne se trouve pas dans des
situations d'isolement et de difficultés
pour utiliser les transports en commun
ce que nous voulons à présent c'est que
des mesures immédiates soient prises et
que ce chèque transport les chômeurs
tous les chômeurs puissent en bénéficier
deuxièmement il faut que nous allions
vers la gratuit la gratuité
donc comme vous le voyez une certaine
déception de la part des représentants
des associations de chômeurs il voulait
donc vous l'avez entendu la gratuité
mais aussi l'extension de ce principe à
l'ensemble du pays alors en deux mots le
principe de ce chèque mobilité ce sera
un petit peu comme les tickets
restaurant 700 francs tous les six mois
contre lesquelles on pourra obtenir un
coupon de carte orange ou un billet
c'est l'état les assedic et la région
qui vont financer cette opération à
hauteur de 400 millions de francs
merci sébastien alors vous n'avez pas vu
martine aubry mais elles devraient
s'exprimer demain sur le mouvement des
chômeurs et nicole notât qui préside
l'unedic pourrait également sortir de
son silence mardi au siège de la cfdt où
elle doit recevoir des membres de
l'association partage une association de
chômeurs il faut savoir que les chômeurs
ne dispose pas de tarifs privilégiés en
matière de transport à quelques
exceptions près dans ce domaine ce sont
souvent les collectivités locales qui
leur viennent en aide
c'est ce qui se passe dans le
département de toulouse où les
transports sont gratuits pour les
chômeurs depuis le printemps 95
christophe la rocker et guy lopez robert
baissé à 50 ans il est au chômage depuis
93 la gratuité des transports ils
l'utilisent depuis un an
depuis qu'il a trouvé un contrat emploi
solidarité pour se déplacer il utilise
ce ticket blanc et gris instauré à
toulouse au printemps 95 un ticket
gagner après dix mois de lutte des
associations de chômeurs et poli par les
syndicats cette carte
aujourd'hui deux photos d'identité et
ensuite le justificatif à se dit que
l'on reçoit la fiche les formalités sont
très simples car aujourd'hui on sait que
ce sont les démarches administratives
qui décourage le plus les personnes
désocialisées à faire valoir leurs
droits grâce à ce système
vingt mille chômeurs mais aussi rmi ce
pcs profitent déjà de la gratuité un
coup pris en charge par la ville de
toulouse le syndicat des communes de
l'agglomération et le département de la
haute-garonne regarde plus cette
impression de budget chaque jour de
savoir ce qu'ils font mais avoir cette
phrase on prendre le métro ou pour
prendre le bus voilà ça salit on est
libéré de d'esprit de ce côté là
pourquoi les chômeurs n'aurait pas droit
à un minimum de vie décentes et c'est ça
qu'on a surtout voulu dire dans notre
manière d'aborder la gratuité faire
gratuité ça sert aussi à se déplacer
pour aller rencontrer les copains pour
aller se déplacer dans le centre ville
pour aller pourquoi pas au cinéma
une chose est sûre robert lui aurait du
mal à se réadapter aux galères de
transport surtout dit-il dans une ville
aussi grande que pas et après la trêve
des confiseurs c'était la grande rentrée
du gouvernement jospin ce matin qui
présentait ses voeux à jacques chirac
l'ambiance était à la cohabitation douce
et respectueuse des prérogatives de
chacun il faut dire que le conseil
constitutionnel a rendu sa décision sur
le traité d'amsterdam pour le ratifier
il faudra en passer par une réforme de
la constitution référendum ou vote du
congrès le choix appartient à jacques
chirac
j'évite imbert et ja gregor
café croissants pour tous le
gouvernement à la table du ministre de
l'intérieur jean pierre chevènement a
respecté la tradition républicaine qui
précède le premier conseil des min c'est
devenu une tradition immuable et comme
la place beauvau siège du ministère se
trouve à 100 mètres de l'elysée
ce jour là les ministres se rendre au
conseil absolue c'est aussi le moment où
ils forment leurs voeux en général assez
conformes à ceux de leurs prédécesseurs
s'y atteler avec les 8
s'améliorer les bonnes habitudes mais
aussi les bonnes manières
le gouvernement a promis lionel jospin
sera scrupuleusement attentif aux
prérogatives du chef de l'état et au
respect de sa personne
jacques chirac lui répète qu'il
s'exprimera aussi souvent que nécessaire
mais pas de cohabitation constructive la
courtoisie est de retour il faut dire
qu'en 98 les deux hommes ont au moins un
objectif commun la marche vers l'europe
et la monnaie unique
le président a confirmé cet après midi
qu'il faudrait réviser la constitution
pour valider le traité d'amsterdam et ce
sujet là ne fait pas débat dans le
couple chirac jospin et à propos de ce
traité d'amsterdam et de la réforme de
la constitution le front national
charles pasqua et robert hue ont déjà
fait savoir la préférence elle va bien
sûr au référendum
robert lui demande même une audition au
chef de l'état à ce propos faut-il y
voir un lien le commissaire au plan rig
hainaut a été remplacé ce matin par jean
michel charpin approche de la gauche
une décision prise en conseil des
ministres avec l'accord de jacques
chirac
henri guaino était un proche de philippe
seguin c'était aussi l'un des principaux
artisans de la campagne du non à
maastricht les explications d'olivier
caroff et de vincent maillard nommé par
jacques chirac il y a deux ans démis ce
matin de ses fonctions par le
gouvernement jospin
l'histoire d'henri guaino n'est banal qu
en apparence car sur son bureau de
commissaire au plan depuis quelques
heures c'est bien de gauche que viennent
les témoignages de sympathie le
mouvement des citoyens plusieurs
syndicats le parti communiste ont appris
à apprécier ce proche de philippe seguin
et de charles pasqua jusqu à l'inviter
dans certains de leurs collègues
d'autres s'était même fendu d'une lettre
ouverte au premier ministre comme marc
blondel le patron de fo ou le socialiste
julien dray mais sans résultat lionel
jospin a obtenu le départ d'henri guaino
on limoge tout simplement parce que
l'existant france un système de pouvoir
qui ne supporte aucune dissidence aucune
différence
aucune dissonance j'ai eu le 112 le
mauvais goût de deux de mettre en
évidence la preuve flagrante
de plus formidable échec collectif que
notre pays est d'enregistrer depuis bien
longtemps et donc de remettre en cause
les choix qui ont été faits depuis une
bonne quinzaine d'années un discours
anti pensée unique qu'henri guaino avait
déjà rodé pour jacques chirac lors de la
présidentielle de 95
alors quand matignon affirme vouloir
simplement relancer le travail du
commissariat au plan
à droite certains ricanent il est
extrêmement désagréable pour un
gouvernement d'avoir quelqu'un qui crie
au feu
alors on pense que le meilleur moyen
d'empêcher le développement l'inde
samedi c'est de faire taire le pompier
d'une partie des gaullistes aux
communistes le cas henri guaino aura
donc réussi à ressouder un camp celui
qui après avoir fait campagne contre
maastricht exige aujourd'hui un nouveau
référendum sur l'europe et cette année
97 a été particulièrement riche en
politique une année folle où quelque
sorte avec la dissolution surprise de
l'assemblée voulue par jacques chirac et
l'arrivée de la gauche au pouvoir retour
en arrière jean baptiste de prêts des
lits
envie gorée par le franc se sont
beaucoup avec beaucoup de joie de
confiance et de détermination début
d'année presque ordinaire après les
fêtes
alain juppé retrouve son gouvernement le
premier ministre reste impopulaire mais
le président de la république lui a
renouvelé sa confiance
personne ne s'en doutent alors mais
jacques chirac à la recherche d'une
initiative songe déjà à dissoudre
l'assemblée nationale en février on
manifeste contre la loi debré le parti
socialiste soutient mais sous-estimé
l'ampleur de la protestation
fin mars jean marie le pen et son parti
tiennent congrès à strasbourg
et pendant que ce congrès là s'amuse
les opposants au fn se mobilisent deux
concerts en manifestation pour la
première fois près de cent mille
personnes défilent dans les rues de
strasbourg
tous les leaders de la gauche ont fait
le déplacement
les socialistes continuent de
s'organiser ils présentent leurs futurs
candidats aux législatives plus de
femmes et de jeunes l'heure est au
renouvellement objectif mars 98
j'ai décidé de dissoudre l'assemblée
nationale aussitôt tout s'emballe
alain juppé est promu chef de campagne
d'une majorité sortante persuadé de sa
victoire
pourtant le nouvel élan invoquée par
jacques chirac peine à s'imposer à
gauche la campagne est déjà plurielle
mais fédérer par le premier secrétaire
du parti socialiste
le premier tour est catastrophique pour
la droite alain juppé indique qu'il ne
souhaite plus retourner à matignon il
s'efface la droite s'en remet alors à
philippe séguin pour un scrutin ont
prédit serré le 1er juin quatre ans
après sa déroute et je sais qu'ils
vivent la gauche est à nouveau au
pouvoir les socialistes ne tiennent pas
à eux seuls la majorité absolue
mais lionel jospin a effacé 93 et les
doutes anciens sur son avenir en
politique
la majorité sera plurielle avec des
communistes et des écologistes
60 de femmes emprunte à l'assemblée
nationale qui se féminise un peu la
troisième cohabitation de la vème
république comment
nommé premier ministre et j'ai accepté
26 ministres dans trois communes i le
gouvernement se veut resserrer cette
cohabitation est inédite président de
droite premier ministre de gauche tous
deux attentifs à leurs prérogatives
au début on parle de cohabitation
courtoise le gouvernement affiche un
style collectif on discute puis lionel
jospin de france la gauche commence à
gouverner il n'y aura ni pause ni recul
ni reniement au rpr dans la tourmente de
l'échec alain juppé c'est de la
présidence du mouvement néo gaulliste à
philippe séguin
devant j'ai ensemble sinon c'est pas
ensemble que nous disparaîtrons en
novembre georges marchais disparaît
emportant 20 années de l'histoire du
parti communiste français
ces erreurs et son déclin à l'extérieur
dès le sommet d'amsterdam la france
parle selon l'expression consacrée d'une
seule voix mais on s'observe on se marre
qu'on se démarque au luxembourg
jacques chirac et bob des
expérimentations hasardeuses
au sujet des 35 heures et je me souviens
d'une expérimentations hasardeuses qui a
débuté le 21 avril 1997 en matière
électorale
à propos d'une dissolution défavorable
il repoussait le soissons nationalité
immigration comme à chaque alternance le
débat politique s'embrase autour de ces
thèmes
sur cette question il ne peut pas vous
nash et vous d'échappée mais vous
apporter de l'eau au moulin de l'extrême
droite l'opposition tentent de retarder
l'adoption des lois sur la nationalité
mais surtout sur l'immigration le
consensus est introuvable
1997 c'est au fond l'année de bien des
surprises en politique dans la nouvelle
cohabitation chacun a pris son rythme
comme si déjà chacun avait en tête
d'autres échéances présidentielles par
exemple une nouvelle découverte dans le
domaine de la lutte contre le sida une
découverte à prendre bien sûr avec
prudence mais qui met en évidence une
sorte de résistance naturelle de
l'organisme au virus à la suite de
mutations génétiques
les explications de françoise vallée et
eric de lannion en dépit des expositions
fréquentes ces hommes n'ont jamais
contracté le virus du sida
c'est l'étude de personnes comme celle
ci qui permet de mieux comprendre les
mécanismes d'entrée du virus dans
l'organisme
pourquoi ces sujets sont ils protégés
pour pénétrer dans la cellule et
l'infecté le vih utilise deux portes on
les appelle des récepteurs le cd4 et le
ccr5 il y a un an une équipe belge a
montré que chez certaines personnes la
porte d'entrée ccr5 était anormal c'est
à dire qu'il existe dans leurs gènes une
anomalie qui bloquent l'entrée du virus
les chercheurs français viennent
confirmer ce résultat ils ont découvert
une autre anomalie du gène qui provoque
les mêmes effets malheureusement très
peu de personnes ont cette anomalie
génétique mais il existe d'autres formes
de résistance au virus pour sanctifier
un peu lâché osé on peut être résistant
là au may h
soit en étant porteur d'un gène
défectueux
j'essaie sur cinq effectués qui
empêchent l'entrée du virus dans la
cellule soit en produisant beaucoup
beaucoup de facteurs seul houle qui
s'appelle de chimiokines cd substance
qui bloque cette protéine a soufflé à
6h05 et qui en bloquant ccr5 empêche
willuth d'entrés vous pouvez exploiter
ce mécanisme peut-être pas photo pour la
mise au point d'un vaccin
si certaines personnes résistent
naturellement et empêchent l'entrée du
virus reste à savoir comment reproduire
les mêmes effets chez des sujets nous
résistant à hong kong les autorités ne
se contente pas d'avoir abattu près d'un
million et demi de volaille
pour combattre la grippe du poulet le
test du virus est maintenant étendue
aura aux chiens et aux chats pour
s'assurer qu'ils n'ont pas à eux aussi
contracté le virus influent dans les
poubelles
aujourd'hui un nouveau cas de grippe du
poulet a été détecté chez un enfant de
trois ans il est pour l'instant
l'enfant est pour l'instant dans un état
satisfaisant l'afflux d'immigrés
clandestins kurdes en italie nous en
parlions hier dans journal un nouveau
bateau a quitté la turquie chargé de
réfugiés économiques
aujourd'hui cette affluence ne laisse
pas d'inquiéter les autres pays
européens
jérôme ni pour ces réfugiés kurdes
l'europe c'est la terre promise fuir le
kurdistan turc et des combats qui ont
fait 28 mille morts depuis 13 ans ils
viennent d'être prises en charge par la
police italienne
ils ont débarqué hier et se voient
délivrer un visa de quinze jours après
quoi ils devront quitter le territoire
italien
quinze jours pendant lesquels ils vont
tout faire pour rejoindre
clandestinement leurs familles déjà
installées en allemagne ou en france
ces réfugiés provoque aujourd'hui une
polémique au sein de l'union européenne
le gouvernement allemand accuse les
italiens de laxisme et les accords de
schengen sur la liberté de circulation
en europe sont mises à mal les autorités
italiennes
elle insiste sur l'aspect humanitaire de
cette migration et propose même
d'accorder à ces kurdes l'asile
politique
la turquie se défend de porter atteinte
aux droits de l'homme mais laisse
l'exode se poursuivre un nouveau bateau
avec 300 réfugiés à son bord a quitté
istanbul ce matin le troisième en huit
jours le pape est attendu dans le centre
de l'italie demain il doit se rendre
dans la région d'assises où un
tremblement de terre a fait 12 morts le
26 septembre dernier et provoqué 38000
sans abri aujourd'hui encore une
nouvelle secousse tellurique a été
ressentie dans la région dans le village
dany fois l'épicentre du séisme beaucoup
d'habitants sont encore dans des
logements précaires le reportage de
philippe rochot et de jacques gérault
la famille baldwin au a voulu revoir sa
maison condamné avant l'arrivée du pape
on a dû dormir dans cette roulotte
pendant un mois après le tremblement de
terre dit béatrice qui n'osaient même
pas pousser la porte de la maison
familiale qui sera détruite dans
quelques jours les pompiers leur ont
interdit d'entrée car elle grâce de
s'écrouler
mais ils n'ont pu s'en empêcher ça me
rend malade de voir sa vie tel et boit
ça me fait pleurer dit son mari
j'ai vécu 66 ans ici on n'est même pas
né dans une clinique mais dans cette
maison justement dit m
sur les soixante maisons que compagnie
faux seule une dizaine sont encore
habitables mais retirée dans les
montagnes de l'ombrie ce village ne
faisait guère parler de lui c'est pour
cela que jean paul ii a choisi de s'y
arrêter
aujourd'hui les habitants vivent dans
ces containers comme la famille baldwin
haut ils ont reçu l'aide des
humanitaires mais pas celle de l'état
car la loi sur la reconstruction n'a pas
encore été voté ils ont pu sauver
quelques meubles mais pas ceux qui les
faisait vivre du tout détruire ils
marient le bétail les fois le grain les
pommes de terre tout est fini
avant l'arrivée du pape la famille
baldwin au a voulu assister à la messe
dans un hangar transformé en salle des
fêtes des prêtres volontaire de caritas
ont voulu célébrer cet office afin que
la visite du pape apporte le réconfort
ou réfugiées d'âme ni faux le père
stefano espère que cette visite va
attirer l'attention du monde chrétien
sur le sort de ces villageois
les gens sont très contents de la visite
du pape
il ne l'attendait pas ils vivent cela
comme un miracle l'irak se demande
comment le pape qui choisira mini faux
jean paul ii n'aura guère que des
prières à apporter aux quarante mille
réfugiés de ce tremblement de terre dont
bris mais sa visite ici devrait relancer
un élan de solidarité qui s'étaient fait
jour dès le lendemain de ce tremblement
de terre et qui tranche avec l'absence
de l'aide publique
un mot maintenant sur le paris-dakar et
la 2e étape entre narbonne et grenade en
espagne chez les autos c'est le français
bruno saby mais qui a une nouvelle fois
remporté l'étape et puis dans la
catégorie motos victoire de l'italien
fabio phase aulas sur ktm
c'est un personnage attachant avec son
accent traînant d'émigrés hollandais
dick annegarn n'avais quasiment disparu
depuis la fin des années soixante dix il
était parti vivre sur une péniche
certains l'avaient ensuite croisées
autour du monde où le voyage est
aujourd'hui il est revenu s'installer à
lille et il sort un nouveau disque
rencontre avec jean jacques dufour et
guillaume fautrat
seulement sept voix c'est celle d'eddie
canet garde
il revient comme ulysse après de beaux
voyages mais une longue trop longue
absence en fait pas devenir un artiste
des autoroutes françaises quoi donc
ce sont 18 j'ai dit bon je quitte la
compétition
je voulais arrêter de courir quoi 78
c'était l'époque des broad scène amateur
de métaphores dick est un poète qu'il ne
puisse pas son inspiration dans le luxe
et la volupté sont nus dans l'assaut ont
fait pas que péter on s'ennuie oui je ne
sais pas ce que j'ai
j'ai commencé à vivre un année depuis
deux ans parce qu'elles sont ma péniche
où je m'ennuyais au paradis
prix de noé
aujourd'hui avec son nouvel album
approche toi certains le découle cette
génération 4g des amis demande en parler
et c'est eux qui m'ont amené ici soir en
france étaient bien les autres leur trou
je n'ai pas compris que ce parcours
moment
tranquille pour vous a pas coupé quoi
bon tant qu il revient après des années
de vaches maigres
dick est toujours en quête de rêve
toujours exigeant les concessions les
modes et notamment celle du jeunisme qui
n'est vraiment pas bonne
le loup casquette renversée comme seul
symbole du héros de 1997 bon non une
page de prêtres aéro et peut être pas je
n'ai jamais voulu être jeune en fait je
ne sais un peu un peu à peu
c'est un peu ce qui quand je pense à
quelque chose ne pas dire qu'on pense
qu'ils bougent enfileront de france
le corps univers brumeux inspiration
mûri et voyageuse le retour de dick est
un vrai bonheur un bonheur aux teintes
mélancolique et douce à l'image de
l'univers d'anne égard combien la notion
de produit comique ou de mélancolie et
joie en même temps au moins de pouvoir
le dire c'est déjà une joie de trouver
le mot juste vous dire une chose crise
voilà je ne résiste pas à la tentation
de vous raconter cette belle histoire de
noël ça se passe à londres 1 au moment
de défaire les paquets un homme s'est
rendu compte qu'il ne trouvait pas le
beau téléphone portable qu'il voulait
ouvrir à l'un de ses amis
alors il eu la merveilleuse idée de
faire sonner téléphone et quand tu es
bien le téléphone a sonné a répondu
c'est son chien en fait qui ce n'est le
chien l'avait tout simplement à vannes
voilà une belle histoire qui peut vous
servir un jour éventuellement les
principaux titres de l'actualité la
tempête balaie l'ouest de la france d
arbre arraché des toitures envolées et
trois morts dont un conducteur le camion
écrasé par la chute danas
la grande braderie des sols être lancées
en région parisienne l'occasion de faire
des affaires à condition toutefois
d'être vigilants les prix affichés the
host être parfois trompeurs et puis une
découverte dans la lutte contre le sida
sous certaines conditions l'organisme
disposerait de ses propres défenses pour
bloquer le virus il s'agirait en fait de
mutations génétiques dans un instant les
prévisions météo isabelle martinez elle
vous dira tout sur les coups de vent
qu'on annonce pour demain à nouveau sur
le grand ouest
et puis après demain avec éventuellement
de nouvelles tempêtes à 20h50
rebecca téléfilm en deux parties à
demain 13h on retrouvera bien sûr
antoine cormery à moi je vous
retrouverai à 20 heures seulement bonne
soirée surprendre
je
ce